la seconde édition du marché pays
spécial fête des mères s'est déroulée au
jardin de l'état ce week end
un rendez vous très apprécié par les
producteurs mais aussi par les
consommateurs qui en profitent pour
trouver une composition florale original
ou des produits locaux à offrir en cette
veille de fête des mères je fais j'ai
ramené une fois construit à l'intérieur
et puis j'ai fait je suis du coup c'est
un grand week-end chrono c'est le cas de
l'année on va dire c'est très
intéressant bien ici on touche beaucoup
de monde et c'est un marché qui est
riche et très très complet et puis c'est
l'occasion de retrouver tous les tous
les marchands fait c'est pas lui c'est
l'endroit idéal
c'est l'endroit idéal face il ya le
cadre il ya tout et qui ont fait cette
petite baie pour minardi en même temps
quoi les enfants lite on s'est baladé il
n'y a pas de voiture c'est pour ces
c'est très sympa au truc une composition
florale des produits cosmétiques à base
de plantes mais aussi des produits
alimentaires sont mises en avant
alors déjà pour offrir aux mamans du
bien-être locale avec du géranium
notamment qui est anti moustiques
musique et relaxation pour la relaxation
vous avez des parfums à base de
géraniums vous avez à base ylang ylang
donc toute une gamme de produits tant au
niveau cosmétique au niveau huiles
essentielles et bon marché spécial fête
des mères et je suis prévu présentés
tous notre production surtout connard
venir le foie gras
donc de programmer les malentendants les
frais comme cela quelqu'un l'a fait on
doit dire qu'elle a refusé on le sait on
le sait chevet 10ème et on le subit de
quoi préparer un repas festif pour nos
mamans après avoir gagné le premier prix
pour sa confiture de letchis lors de la
foire agricole
emmanuel sablé est présente pour faire
découvrir ses autres parfums on propose
de venir découvrir en fait toute la
gamme de confitures parce qu'on fait pas
que le déficit on fait on fait beaucoup
de fruits fruits longtemps on à dassa
tout il ya des tomates arbustes il ya
des choses plus faciles genre de la
moule du goyavier aussi on a nié de
jaboticaba si aujourd'hui ça c'est des
petits fruits qu'on a dans la course et
à des grosses productions donc c'est on
met en avant toutes les petites
productions une manifestation qui permet
à la collectivité de soutenir le monde
agricole et la production pays ainsi que
de répondre à la forte demande du public
et des producteurs locaux
il faut pour favoriser ce qu'on appelle
le circuit court en un mot c'est le
producteur qui vend directement ses
produits aux consommateurs en pariant
sur le fait qu'il y aura bien sûr moins
cher et conrad est doté de bonnes
qualités c'est la première deuxième
chose et de se dire allons faire
fonctionner les marchés des produits
locaux consommons pays de la besoins et
fit simone
il y avancer et c'est en moyenne
participer avec lui mais rudnevs que
d'acheter d'acheter ici d'acheter local
et enfin notre ligne chose c'est la fête
des mères donc j'espère qu effectivement
que les ravit mais aussi voir les uns et
les autres trouveront de quoi satisfaire
leurs besoins en cadeau pour que toutes
les mamans en soit est une bonne fête
des mères dans une émission spéciale
fête des mères qui attire toujours plus
de monde